SPEAKER: For this episode
of "BigQuery Spotlight,"
we're putting the
you in BigQuery.
Meaning it's time
to start asking
questions of your own data.
For today's episode, you'll
learn how to load and analyze
your own data in BigQuery.
And by the end,
you'll have the data
you need to answer the
age-old question-- which
is better, cats or dogs?
For the results
of that match-up,
you'll have to stick around.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you want to
analyze data that's
not already available as
part of the public data
sets program or hosted publicly
by another BigQuery user,
you'll need to load your
own data into BigQuery.
How you load the data depends
on your analytics needs
and your data pipeline.
If your data slowly
changes or needs
to be loaded in a
one-time analysis,
you may be fine with loading
the data into BigQuery in batch.
But if you need to
ingest and analyze
data close to real
time, in this case,
you may need to stream
your data into BigQuery.
Luckily, BigQuery has
options for loading data
that cover both of these
scenarios and those in between.
Let's show you
how to get started
by loading data in batch.
So what data do you
need in BigQuery
in order to officially crown the
winner of the cats versus dogs
battle?
We're going to determine the
champion by analyzing college
basketball tournament
games in order
to see who wins when
dog mascots and cat
mascots go head to head.
To run this analysis,
we'll need two things.
First, we'll need to have the
tournament results data, which
is already available in BigQuery
as part of the public NCAA
basketball public data set.
We introduced this public
data set in our episode
on how to query in
BigQuery, which is linked
below if you're interested.
Second, we'll need a list that
has teams with dog and cat
mascots, which we have
available as a local CSE file.
It's also linked below if
you're following along.
To join these two data
sets together for analysis,
we'll need to load the
mascot CSE file into BigQuery
and create a table.
No time to waste.
Let's get started.
Let's first create a home for
the mascot table in BigQuery.
BigQuery organizes data into
containers called data sets.
These data sets function
like top-level folders
that organize and control
access to the underlying tables.
Let's head over to the web UI.
If you want to follow
along, pause the video,
click on the link
in the description
below to set up your
own BigQuery sandbox,
where you can load
and analyze data
without needing a credit card.
All right, on to the UI.
To create a new data set,
select the project name
on the left-hand nav and click
the Create Data Set button.
We'll give the data set a name
and then decide on a location.
In this case, we
need to co-locate
our data set with the NCAA
public data set, which is
located in the US multi region.
We'll need to reference
both tables in one query
by performing a join.
And this can only
be done with tables
residing in the same
geographical location.
You can always view
the data set location
by clicking on the
Details tab in the web UI.
Click Create Data Set
and the new data set
will appear in
the left-hand nav.
Now it's time to create a
new table within the data set
by loading the mascot CSE file.
Highlight the data set
and click Create Table.
This dialog allows
us to directly upload
files from our local machine
up to 10 megabytes in size
and containing less
than 16,000 rows.
If you have something
larger, don't worry.
You can just upload it
to Cloud storage and then
select it from there.
Since our CSE is
pretty small, we
can skip that and use
the browse functionality
to select the file
from our local machine.
Give the table a name and
then define the schema.
The schema is a list of each
column and its data type.
We can define the
schema manually
by clicking on Add
Field or check the box
to have BigQuery auto-detect it.
Click Create Table and a
load job will be created.
Once the data has
finished loading,
you can navigate to
view the table details,
review the schema, and preview
the data right in the console.
Our mascots table
is ready to query.
We'll paste in a query
that uses the mascot
table to analyze cat versus
dog tournament game match-ups.
In our query, we've started with
our table of tournament games,
and then used a series of SQL
joins with the mascots table
to look up to animal
classification
for the winning
and losing teams.
We then sum up the
number of wins for cats
and the number of wins for dogs
in the specific cat versus dog
match-up games.
Time to run our query.
And there we have it-- with 43
of the wins, dog mascots reign
supreme in the realm of college
basketball tournament games.
The analysis doesn't
have to stop there.
You can see how dogs and
cats perform on other metrics
or join this data with other
data sets to test new ideas.
For example, do the
types of mascots
different between warmer
and colder climates?
Comment below with your ideas
of exploring the mascots table.
We hope you look out
for our next episode
of "BigQuery Spotlight."
And remember, stay curious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]